welcome to this video playing st.
thinkin Lincoln whatever from from the
UK and maybe yeah maybe try for the
blumenfeld again this was entertaining
the last couple of times to just take it
you know is playing you for a friend of
mine recently told me that this isn't
too bad for white remarkable remarkable
but quite sure what the point is how it
has a decent development surely I am
yeah I see it what chick here yeah maybe
I should still take like we know 6d 556
m IE 6 porn can be can be really we can
still hope that the activity is is good
enough Bishop g5 okay I want I wanted to
Oh interesting
yeah I don't know maybe he wants to
really play we should be too we are
either then d 4 is better than playing d
4 immediately okay yeah I will do that
you can give this check here but I mean
my bishops are quite something so should
I yeah probably let's let's get out of
this check and then yeah okay with this
this is not not not not on here I don't
believe that 95 now IM he cannot take
because of the made on g2 hmm okay
checkmate I'll take it I'll take it yeah
it was it was a trickier anyway however
I think he lost so much time here with
all those pawn moves around here this
shouldn't be too bad for white it's at
least a playable position i guess but
this song this now starts to be very
very problematic with both bishops
raking down the board on on the king
yeah this is uh oh this is already
winning yeah I should have thought about
that Bishop takes Queen FY it's very
it's very easy actually Angie three wins
the PCM if he goes here take a cake and
rook e8 or whatever I mean I'm breaking
through on edge too but this this wasn't
bad as well he yeah I probably must play
something like 91 and this is a very
very problematic oh the comp gives the
funny when 94 Bishop g4 queen age 6
that's really nice page three Queen f4
is going to be a checkmate
so you must play this Andrew care for
takes takes is also wonderful black hair
quite nice okay very quick game but I
like to take the point thanks for
watching